oh hey you may have caught our video
last year where we fixed the worst vfx
shot of all time
what if i told you there's something
even worse
what if i told you that there is a movie
where every shot is the worst
vfx shot ever made
[Music]
so there is a movie from a very long
time ago called the birds
the movie was directed by alfred
hitchcock
that's his name from now on just alfred
so that was a movie about like the birds
kind of rising up and starting to just
attack people for no reason well i guess
flying down oh yeah rising up the
opposite of rising up
but burdemic is a completely different
piece of artisanal work erdemic is
similar to the room in that it was a
very low budget
film it has a cult following because of
its
janky nature you guys seeing that on
visual effects artists react
it was like wait a second this would be
the perfect job
for the crew and maybe we do some
re-editing maybe we do some
new music but mostly we got some new vfx
in there now i know this is sacrilegious
we are touching a
perfect piece of artwork that shouldn't
be touched but we're going to kind of
put on our george lucas hat a little bit
and hopefully
kind of try to make verdemic kind of
good question i have though is if we
make it slightly better is that going to
make it less entertaining
i mean that that is actually kind of a
worry see birdemic works because they
tried so hard to make it good
but it's burdemic now peter
you don't even know what birdemic is no
never seen it are the effects good yes
the effects are flawless peter reacts to
birdemic
let's hop into it
all i remember is this music just
playing over and over and over
again james wynn that's his name he
directed this masterpiece
whoa oh they're in the park looking at
the birds that's so cute
those are just the those are the intro
birds
there's an explosion the birds bomb
things all right so this is it
we just went from zero to birdemic in
like half a second
my god this is what we're talking about
peter
this is the good stuff they're just like
here come the birds oh
what was that bird vomit that was bird
gunga i wonder how the actors
felt about this while shooting it you
know were they like into it
[Music]
if we're going to try to elevate
verdemic i think we need to add
something new to the birds
if we just add in modern effects of
birds
like sure we can do that we can paint
out the existing birds we can track in
new 3d models render them out but how do
we elevate the scene and make it
something new
yeah i mean we could take the corridor
lens the cinematic vfx action scene lens
and apply it to this movie
just make it epic man yeah dude but i
like the idea of likes so they're
fighting off regular birds i mean
regular updated birds but then it
ends with a boss sequence a boss battle
what if we gave them this really
muscular arm dude just super like
like they got the wings they got the
legs but they also just have these super
buff arms so it's like
it lands like homelanders like
yeah and then the arms come out like i'm
thinking something that looks like the
ball rock
yeah that's what hold up what did you
just ask
what the heck is a balrog
balrogs oh and what are the rings oh i
saw those movies
we have a lot of building blocks for a
cool scene to work with we have a lot of
shots of them shooting out the window
a lot of shots of birds obviously if you
guys start on the birds
i'll start on the edit and then we
reconvene later this week let's
let's put your put your wings in ready
and okay while the guys are out in l.a
the land of no birds
they asked me to come to texas and to
film some in their natural habitat so
that while they're doing this burdemic
remake courtesy of today's sponsors
squarespace they've got some really good
solid foundational research to go off of
the first thing you're going to want to
know about
birds is that birds have a migratory
range
now this is very similar to
squarespace's beautiful award-winning
templates with 24
7 award-winning customer service because
through that beautiful range of options
you're going to be able to explore
all of the migratory space of the
internet by creating
a beautiful website yourself the next
thing you're going to want to know about
birds
is that they exist in families and just
like squarespace's multiple contributors
tool
you'll be able to work with your family
of other creators with different levels
of access to your website
interesting fact about birds they create
nests
through squarespace's audio blocks
feature you can
nest audio on your website and that will
go out natively to a bunch of other
platforms so
if you have a podcast you can nest your
podcast on your website and that'll go
out to anyone who wants to listen to it
another key thing when really
understanding what birds are all about
is having a great overview tool such as
this book i'm using right here
with squarespace's traffic overviews
tools
people who use squarespace will be able
to understand who comes and goes from
their website and the last thing that i
really want the guys to know
just head on over to squarespace.com
corridor crew
and you'll get 10 off the first purchase
of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com corridor crew look at
that
look at those guys these are owls
so when it comes to the edit there's two
things that we really want to hit one is
redoing the birds making them actually
look like birds
that are evil that are trying to kill
people and then two
is actually showing a bird's death like
a cool bird kill
for a movie that's marketed as birdemic
shock and terror a surprisingly small
amount of it is actually action scenes i
mean the director himself
james nguyen describes this as a romance
horror
the romance and the character
development james has got that covered
as far as the characters fighting birds
and actually having like a cool action
scene with them there's really not much
whitney moore who's the actress in this
what we want is for her to have a moment
where she finally gets a cool bird kill
she never had it so hopefully we can
finally give that to her
the thing is there's literally like one
shot of her firing a dang gun
in that scene so that's all we have to
work with as far as like
a heroic character moment here what we
need for the scene
is a character moment where she says
something or like the camera holds on
her
to show this reveal of her coming to
save the day and kill this bird
there's nothing though we gotta find a
way to get some shots
of her looking really badass but it
turns out that clint actually knows
whitney
we might be able to get her to actually
come in to shoot some shots let's go see
hey hey what's up boys
hey whitney how you doing good how are
you guys doing doing all right
i've seen this movie too many times
when you were on set doing this did you
have an idea like what did you see in
your head how did you imagine
these these birds looking the thing is
on set being just the guy and the other
guy and me
like instantly i was like this is gonna
be
so bad yeah so yeah there was never a
moment where i was like
man yeah cool
[Laughter]
so basically we kind of like reframed it
so that there's like this boss bird holy
[ __ ]
and it's up to you at the end of this
thing and like you get your redemption
moment like you get a sweet
bird kill in this thing
the only thing we're missing is like one
character beat
from your character in this thing i
don't know if you'd be down
to come in for one green screen pickup
yeah i'm totally have you all been good
boys and getting tested
we get tested regularly okay i'm excited
see you guys
see ya peace all right awesome great
wednesday at noon today whitney is here
she's going to be our actress for these
shots
i feel like i'm getting some ptsd
flashbacks
it does feel good to put it on in in a
new context
[Music]
weird i just had this weird flashback to
the scene when you're actually firing in
the movie
you have like the same motion like
hey bird brain peck on someone your own
size
hey burban beg on someone your own dad
what's another good like derogatory bird
term
that we got that's a federal offense
that's ill eagle
you're gonna need medical treatment hey
feather face
two can play at this game
that's a wrap was it literally just you
guys and him and
it was the three of us usually with like
putting a boom
stick between my legs to like catch
audio yeah
it was the first audition that i got uh
after after i graduated high school i
was like i can
try to do movies now and i auditioned in
a parking lot which should have been the
first red flag but
it wasn't and then he called me an hour
later to say that i got it
second red flag how long are you guys
shooting for for that thing
seven months
on weekends though but still uh so
so much you shot green screen footage
that never made it a ton
of greens so much we also shot the love
scene like
eight times
oh boy i think that he wanted to just
make the birds
and from what i know of like the way
hitchcock conducted himself on set
i could tell he was like really trying
to be
that sort of auteur he self-references
very often as an auteur and
uh bless him blossom
were those visual effects better or
worse than you are expecting i think
somehow worse
like they i mean because they looked
like two-dimensional
and even he has said like the graphics
weren't
up to par but he says that if you like
squint your eyes that they
they look good or like you know he he
gives it a lot of
he's like well you get it you you get
what i'm going for and so it's good
and yeah i like i can joke about it now
because it was a
really traumatic experience but has also
led me to meet
almost every friend that i've had in la
and i love b-movies so
yeah it's i can look back on it and
laugh but at the time it was
a truly miserable experience
we're gonna try and add some legit bird
effects in this so we'll see
what we can do my expectations the bar
is very very low
so you might be wondering what this boss
bird is going to look like i am
wondering
oh my god oh my god
the biggest
[Laughter]
dude it's so good good job lads
thanks again bye-bye got the shots it's
time to finish the effects finish the
edit
get this thing finished so we can give
whitney the catharsis
she deserves
[Music]
dude this is like a really high quality
bald eagle model
i don't know how to model a bald eagle
but fortunately someone else already did
on turbo squid
clint's going to tell you about how he
made the actual swarms but we have some
birds that fall out of the sky and slam
onto the ground
and that's my responsibility to make
happen first thing i decided to try
doing was to turn this bird
into like a ragdoll physics simulation
right so it's like
has all the lens flopping around like a
bird you know like getting run over by
vans however cinema 4d doesn't really
have a super easy way to do rag dolls
so what i ended up turning to was soft
body physics
so there's a great tutorial for my
design on how to basically rig up any
object to be a soft body physics thing
the idea behind is that you basically
model a really low poly
cage around your model and simulate that
as a soft body physics
object and then you link your model to
that soft body and it'll deform it the
same way
so that way you don't have to go through
all the processing power of having to
like simulate
millions of polygons you just simulate a
few dozen link it to your high quality
mesh and your mesh
will actually deform the same way i just
baked that out i import it into my
camera track scene of the van
and play it on the ground
that's it that's the shot now all this
shot needs is a huge flock of birds
clint whip your flock out
i'm not gonna do that we have a lot of
birds to add to all these shots
and we can't be doing a bird one by one
hand picking birds and where they go no
we need to simulate it with artificial
intelligence
ren you sent me a little something
i don't like that language dean i don't
either that's mean
boyd's stands for bird oid objects voids
is basically
a way to measure how flocks of birds
move a flock of birds are basically
governed by three
individual factors we have coherence
that's basically
the flock trying to find each other
they're trying to
orbit back to the main group separation
that's just how far apart
they stay from each other in alignment
if you want to learn about how
flocks work and all this stuff basically
how we're simulating these birds
destined from smarter everyday already
made the perfect video for you to watch
now lucky for us we're using x particles
and x particles is an advanced particle
simulation
plug-in for cinema 4d it actually has a
flock modifier
that has specific parameters allowing me
to control
the motion of these particles it's an
experiment until you get the right
look and then what i do is i have to rig
up a bird
animate a bird flap in its wings you
know it's just a loop
and then i take that bird and i
basically say hey
anywhere where there's a particle make
it a bird
this animated bird instead and then from
that point
you got a flock of birds going james
next time you're making burdemic 3c
eagle just maybe keep three things in
mind
coherence separation and alignment
so the crux of this burdemic remake is
going to be
whitney's fight with the boss bird so i
had to make a boss bird that is so
imposing
that its death would bring satisfaction
to whitney
for years to come and maybe james as
well who knows
but i'm gonna take you through how i
made it i'm thinking this bird should be
a real beefcake
i thought the best way to do that would
be with this free software called make
human it's awesome
muscles all the way up wait all the way
up
this is this is what the rock looked
like when he was five years old oh
this was the most important in blender
we bring in our dude
basically what i've done is i've taken a
man and i've chopped off
all of his extremities and all of his
extremities and replaced them with
eagle parts so we got some good wings
here i took the arms and i
sawed off the hands and i stretched the
backs of the arms out
so we get a little flappiness for the
feathers we're using a hair system but
instead of rendering hair we are
rendering an object instead and that
object is just a picture of a feather
you might remember in the time capsule
video i went over rigging and i kind of
went through the same process here what
i did was i brought in the skeleton and
then i manually
lined that up with the bird model and
then i asked blender
to pair the two and it did it
automatically and it was pretty much
flawless i didn't need to do any
tweaking
so i got my bird model all set up from
this point all i need to do is hop in a
rococo motion capture suit
bang out some shots pick my camera
angles render those out and we're good
to go
it's a week later and we have our
finished birdemic
recut clint and ren can't join us today
that are both out but
we have the crew here we're going to
show them what we came up with i feel
bad for ren and clint
these days movie theaters are closed
filmmakers don't get to show
their works in a public setting here and
these two guys are missing out
i don't know how these guys convinced us
to spend a week and a half of company
time and money on like fixing just a
really crappy movie
but they did it i hope it's funny
you guys have the lead actress from the
movie
these are some large forces colliding
here like this is gonna be incredible
[Music]
there's birds everywhere come on we
gotta lose them
all right i think we lost him oh [ __ ]
tank's empty pull over here
look out here comes that big
move bird got
hey this brain peck on someone your own
[Music]
size
huh
i'm so impressed because like that first
shot play i'm like whoa wait this is the
actual movie
i thought you were gonna be like
rebuilding the movie but like
having to put those birds back over the
footage like wow
i gotta say like the amount of technical
prowess and like the polish here
this is like this is the most
well-engineered shiny turd i've ever
seen
they made a mold of that turd and then
they cast that turd
in like perfect like steel and chromed
it out and then they hydro dipped it in
the coolest pattern
it's like it is like so cool just the
shots of them shooting the guns out of
the window is so great
like that that's really good yeah did
you track guns into our hands
clint like put an smg and a rocket
launcher into her hand so that's amazing
it's really funny how he had the orange
chip on this the smg with the orange tip
he was that was fake yeah but he kept
the word no that's where i was like oh
this is the real
movie because there's an orange chip and
it matches the insanity because the
original jake is still in there
i guess the new version loses a little
bit of that original charm that the
original had because
it was trying really hard to be good but
didn't quite get there and that
made it kind of charming i don't know we
we reached this weird uncanny valley
where it doesn't have that original
charm but it has a new
kind of feel to it so uh i don't really
know what to make of it
are there any other janky movies you
guys want to see redone leave a comment
below letting us know
and also we've done a ton of other kind
of vfx makeovers or r-rated makeovers of
other movies
they're really fun videos to watch check
them out there's a playlist on the
screen right now
has all of them compiled for you if you
haven't seen it you're missing out
so click that playlist click it
click